let me say it quick thank you to today's
new member of the day John Harvey the
second I also want to say thanks to Mark
Dimmit who is today's longtime Hall of
Fame sustaining member of the day with
us almost 5 years John and Mark thank
you this is a program that's mostly
funded by viewers through the membership
program and by listeners through the
membership program if you've been here
for a while if you like the show if
you'd like to see the show continue
consider supporting us it doesn't take a
lot of money to move the needle I get
emails all the time from people saying I
want to contribute a hundred bucks a
month so I but I can't afford it
so I'm contributing nothing to which I
say will contribute 3 bucks a month use
the coupon code this is 20/20 which will
drop a $6 a month membership to just
three dollars and 60 cents for the month
that is more than enough to move the
needle if enough people do it and I
really appreciate everybody who has been
supporting us including a record more
than 350 new members in the month of
January alone let's go to the phones at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty and see what's on people's
minds let's start with our caller from
the six six one area code who's this
what's on your mind today
hey David this is a Jose from California
hey Jose what's going on
how's it going I have a question with
the recent attack in Syria and the death
of US servicemen out there I think I
read it was to this morning is it gonna
be a lot tougher to pull out it's just
in general or it's just gonna complicate
things more and keep us there even
longer I think it was always going to be
tough to pull out of Syria I mean right
after Donald Trump made the announcement
you heard from John Bolton I mean John
Bolton chiming in and saying you know
yes we want to leave but there are
strategic objectives which have to first
be met and it's not exactly clear when
we're going to be doing it and then
Trump came back and said oh no we're
leaving and we're leaving soon I mean I
think that the most important point is
we've still not left and okay it takes
more than a few weeks but it's already
been a few weeks and so far nothing's
happening I don't think that the deaths
that you're talking about make it any
easier
but I think it was already going to be
pretty darn complicated to just get out
of there yeah no I agree also I would
like for a sleep relax or asleep Iraq
I would like to so as to leave
Afghanistan and it's just going to be
harder and harder as the at the time
those my last question is do you support
a mass pullout or do you support stayin
and just making sure the Kurds are in
good standing before we leave I'm
totally fine with leaving Syria in
principle and I was against getting
involved in the first place my concern
now is that the timing of Trump choosing
to bail out is suspicious in three or
four different ways which I've pointed
out and I would want to make sure that
we don't imperil the Kurds so I'm for
the u.s. not being involved in Syria I
want to make sure that choosing now is
the time to leave doesn't but that it
fits in and has a strategic sort of
thought process that has been applied
right right I agree with that all right
thank you for the call really appreciate
it great to hear from you